Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie. This will be my Full
Ahsoka Episode 3 Video
There are a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references, so we'll break it all down
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes.
We're also doing the giveaway
for those Star Wars echo dots.
All you have to do to enter
is be subscriber in post
all your predictions
and theories in the comments below.
Careful.
Postpone us from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet,
we'll just start at the beginning
and work our way through. Shot by shot.
Talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
starting with the episode
titled Time to Fly,
which is a reference
to a couple of different things
to their dog fight against the Darksiders
in general.
Them taking off on their mission
to stop that from
bringing Thrawn back
with the super hyperdrive.
this is also meant to be a big reference
to the prequels.
The space whales in the reason
why they were at that planet Seatos,
why the purrgils were in the atmosphere
through all those clouds.
This is a reference back to the Star Wars
Rebels episode where they kind of explain
how the prequels actually survive.
part of the idea is that
they can navigate hyperspace naturally,
but in order for that part of their body
to function, for them to live
that way, they have to consume
special hyperdrive gases.
They get refined by normal people
and put in regular ships.
So the idea is that
the CTOs planet is meant to be kind of
like a refueling station in a cosmic sense
on the path that the prequels
take to this other galaxy.
It's like the last stop
on the way to the other galaxy
before they jump off on their trip.
Before it's time for the pergolas to fly,
so to speak,
that's why this special ancient record,
an empire waypoint here with the map
is the last destination
before the big trip to that other galaxy,
like where they're specifically
building the hyperdrive ring here.
the whole idea is this is like the last
stop on the way to the other galaxy.
a lot of people
also asking you about this new intro here.
They swapped it a little bit
for the Ahsoka series
with all the different heads
and the helmets of the different droids.
So the new ones are the clone
trooper helmet, because so much of
this is referencing back to the Clone Wars
in the Star Wars Rebels episodes.
HK Droid heads because the HK Droids
Morales Inquisitor helmet
chopper himself and who Yang's head
all the other heads are
the familiar ones that you saw
at the beginning
of the Mandalorian episodes,
the other Star Wars episodes.
noticed during the opening scene, too,
that the music starts
in that same Japanese
samurai film inspired type of music.
The whole idea is that the Ahsoka series
is meant to be more inspired by Samurai
films like George Lucas was inspired
by during the original Star Wars trilogy.
that's why a lot of the designs,
the way that Ahsoka has her ship here,
like even her training room here
and who Yang is talking about using
traditional Jedi fighting forms, sound
very samurai, very martial arts inspired.
the actual
opening scene is of Sabine
Wren being trained in the traditional Jedi
fighting forms with a bunch of lightsabers
that Yang is using now,
other holographic lightsabers
like training lightsabers.
But if you look on the wall here,
a soldier has what looks like
at least nine different lightsabers.
see, you can let me know who you think
these belong to.
one of them might be cannons light saber.
But Ezra Bridgers lightsaber
actually belongs to Sabine right now.
She has that.
my guess is Ahsoka just slowly picked up
light saber hilts along the way,
and she's just using them here.
The other funny moment here
too, is who Yang using for different
lightsabers
is a bit of a callback to General Grievous
during Revenge of the Sith
because a lot of this is referencing
the events of the prequels
with Anna and Skywalker in order 66
when he starts using
these traditional terms
ki say akira gei yada.
They're all part of traditional Jedi
fighting forms
that would have been used
when teaching Patton's back
as far as the Old Republic,
because Hou Yang is an old Republic droid.
They keep making jokes about that
during the episodes about his programing,
the traditional Jedi programing
that was given to him.
So everything that he says, like
his protocols
are all based on things that are many,
many thousands of years old.
generally the entire room is meant
to look very similar
to the room that they saw
inside the Lothar Jedi Temple.
When Kanan learned that
the Grand Inquisitor actually used to be
one of the Jedi Temple Guardians.
the set up here
too, is meant to look like
a traditional martial arts fighting dojo.
For instance, the helmets are meant
to look like kendo helmets
because kendo inspired a lot
of the traditional Jedi fighting styles.
When George Lucas was creating lightsaber
fights for the original trilogy.
when she starts referencing the taichi,
that's actually a real life reference to
the torch, i.e. The Blind Swordsman.
he was a fictional character,
a blind master swordsman.
During the Edo period.
There have been tons of novels,
tons of movies based on the character.
They're all great.
I would recommend checking out
some of them if you haven't before.
but the funny thing is that Dave Filoni
is also saying that in the Star Wars
universe, Satoshi was a canonical Jedi
at some point in the history
who developed these fighting styles
that Ahsoka is using to train Sabine,
she also references beings and Mandalorian
trained skills, just more references
to her being a Mandalorian.
I just did a video about how
Sabine and Grogu, who are both the future
of the Mandalorian Jedi.
they make a couple references to
Mandalorian Jedi later in the episode too.
I'll talk about that in a second.
they're a couple very on the nose.
Luke Skywalker references when she tries
to train her with the kendo helmet.
this is meant to be almost
the exact same type of scene as Luke
training with the Blaster
helmet in the exact same dialog.
in universe
they're calling the wooden swords
that they're using to train Sabine
with Barkin's sabers Buck in or actually
a real life type of Japanese wooden
sword used for training in Kenji TSU.
So a lot of the series
is taking from Real world inspiration.
when a soldier starts
talking about how anger and frustration
gives you more power in battle,
she's talking about
the dark side of the force
unbalancing you.
Being a side effect is also a reference
to how Obi-Wan was ultimately able
to defeat Enoch and Skywalker on Mustafar,
even though Anakin Skywalker
was vastly more powerful than Obi-Wan,
that's probably going to be a clue in
how Ahsoka is going to be able
to defeat Balan's skull,
or at least not get killed by him
or save herself from being killed by him
because he does seem like he's
going to be way more powerful.
part of the problem with that, though,
is that it seems like he's actually
accounted for, that like his path to
the force isn't completely towards
the way of the Sith.
So he's found a better way to harness
some of that extra power of the dark side
without some of the downsides.
Then we go back to home.
One of the New Republic fleet.
You see a bunch of wings fly by Monmouth.
Momma comes back with a bunch of other
new senators that we haven't seen before,
But there are a couple connections
to canonical characters.
this senator's
yono is meant to be the father of Kazuto
from the new Resistance
TV show from the sequel movie era.
all the others except for Monmouth
are meant to be brand new characters.
most of you could probably predict
how this was going to go though.
Like they obviously want Thrawn to have
this giant war against the New Republic.
They want to have their Star War
The whole idea is the New Republic
can't be prepared
because if they were prepared
then Thrawn would never be able
to mass the Shadow council
and bring them together.
so they have a reverse logic
kind of situation where the plot needs
the New Republic to be super dumb.
the whole idea is that everybody
still thinks that Thrawn is dead.
All he disappeared during the battle
of Atholl like he's been dead for years.
But we worry about him coming back.
The remnants of the empire all scattered
because they don't know about the Shadow
Council either.
What seems like is that man
Mathema is the only one who's
actually concerned
about the threat of threat.
Like, Oh, she remembers.
Oh, Thrun, you're talking about him
coming back. Oh, crap.
but all the other senators seem like
they don't want to alarm
the general citizens with another war,
like we don't want to worry or burden
people with the thought of another war.
Redditor the original trilogy in the War
against the Empire.
So even if they're not meant to be super
shady, they're still trying
to bury their heads in the sand
and just pretend like there is no problem.
I think the idea is they
probably wouldn't have believed Hera
unless they saw Thrawn in orbit.
Of course, like they're going to wait
till the very final moment
when Thrawn shows up with his giant fleet
in the bay like OC.
Maybe there's a problem after all.
and also there
probably are a couple imperial loyalists
who are part of the Senate.
most of them, though,
especially some of the ones
that are on this high council here, seem
like they're just more opportunist,
like we're just kind of waiting to see who
comes out on top and we'll support them.
you notice during their argument here
with here against them, the other thing
that gets mentioned way more
than I expected was Ezra Bridger himself.
probably just for a new viewers
for their benefit to remind you like,
oh, there is stakes.
Like they do have a friend
they're trying to say,
but it's weird that he would be such
a huge figure in the New Republic Senate.
what probably happen
is that after the Battle of Lothal,
after Thrawn was defeated in
the Seventh Fleet was taken
by the Pergolas to this other galaxy,
the members of the Gos probably explained
to the rebellion forces at the time
because it wasn't the New Republic yet
they were only able to defeat
Thrawn, defeat the Imperial Fleet here
because of Ezra Bridger.
So they just canonized him
as this huge hero.
So going forward, everybody just
thought of this really big hero
That's why I'm wondering there's
going to be a huge twist when they reveal
what really happened to Ezra.
Like, is he going to wind up
being the Marrok character
or is something else really shady going
to wind up happening with this character?
why would they keep building up the myth,
the legend of Ezra Bridger,
if there wasn't going to be some huge
rug pull moment
when they actually reveal
what happened to him?
so just keep that
in the back of your mind.
part of the idea with Mon Mothma
here, too, is that even though
it seems like she's sympathetic to Hera
and wants to help her,
she doesn't wield dictatorial power
the way that Palpatine
did during the last days of the republic
and then during the empire.
So at least right now her hands are tied,
Monmouth also references Jacen Syndulla.
A lot of people wondering
if he was going to be on the series.
They finally confirm when they show him
during the actual series
he was in the trailers,
but we only saw the back of his head,
so it wasn't really clear
how they were going to be using
the character Notice that Jacen seems
a little bit older than he did during that
rebels ending scene.
And we see chopper here with them.
They have some more jokes about him
just revealing all the secrets,
which I think is a bit of a joke
about R2-D2
being this droid
that has all the knowledge,
all the secrets from the prequels,
but never really tells anybody about it.
During the original trilogy, like part
of the joke of Star Wars is that R2-D2
remembered everything from the prequels
when C-3PO had his mind wiped.
he would even have remembered Grogu
when he saw him again
during the Mandalorian season two.
Like, Oh man, is that little baby Yoda
that we saw a long time ago?
back when he was in against Droid
at the Jedi Temple before Order 66.
they also have a seen
answering a lot of people's questions
about Jacen's future too.
Will he be trained by a soldier
in the force because he says to Hera
I want to become a
Jedi. I do just like Sabine.
The thing is, he's actually
about the right age to become a Padawan,
almost a little too old to become a part
about, remember, and a kid
who was almost too old
to join the Jedi Temple when he joined.
normally children are selected
when they're about four years old.
Jacen
Obviously much, much older than that.
for the most part, he looks just like
he did during the animated series.
He's got the same green hair.
The reason why he doesn't have head
tails is because he's half human and half.
Tulloch.
there was even a brief moment
where Hera pauses
when they're referencing
Kanan and becoming a Jedi
like she was trying to remember him.
It sounds that they they played a
little bit of his theme during then, too.
maybe.
If we're lucky,
we'll get a flashback scene with Kanan
or some kind of Kanan force ghost scene
Freddie Prinze Jr keeps saying that
he didn't do any kind of live action
cameos, scenes or anything like that,
but he could just be doing
that actor thing where you lie.
People lie about that kind of stuff
all the time.
I heard about it
and I did see it and it's a Photoshop.
Oh, they go back to a ghost ship.
It looks like they're drinking tea,
not blue milk.
Any time anybody's drinking anything
in Star Wars, you always try to check it.
They're drinking more blue milk.
They confirmed that
Sabine is more sensitive,
like they have a conversation
about that, like,
oh, she has a low aptitude this year.
I temple wouldn't take her,
but they're just trying to confirm that
she is basically for sensitive, does it.
Her aptitude for learning things
and connecting with the force
isn't as great as someone like Aniket
or more powerful Jedi.
her using the force to joint the coffee.
Talking about starting small is also
a wink at Grogu you on the Mandalorian
using the force
all the time to steal more food.
who. Yang's argument with the Sokka
about traditional Jedi teachings,
what the Jedi order
would have wanted for us to be.
No, no, they wouldn't have taken her.
Her attitude isn't high
enough with the force
is more about a soldier trying to
turn away from the traditional Jedi rules
like she didn't believe
in a lot of the Jedi Council's rules,
which is one of the reasons
why she left the order back in the day.
So that's why who Yang says, Oh, well,
you know,
you also came
from a line of nontraditional Jedi.
It makes sense
that Sabine would also become
another nontraditional type of Jedi.
the line, who Yang is talking about
is her coming from and Akin Skywalker,
who was a nontraditional Jedi.
And from quite on, Jane,
who also disagreed with the council
all the time when they referenced
previous Mandalorians
who became Jedi, like,
there were very few of them, really.
There was just the one.
And it was TAA Vizsla about a thousand
years ago who created the Darksaber
then went back to the Mandalorian people
to lead his culture.
Grogu who in Sabine would be like
the next actual Jedi
who could call themselves
Mandalorian Jedi?
I literally just did a video about this.
How about they're basically
the future of Mandalorian Jedi
and the future of the Jedi Order
the whole thing, though, is Ahsoka says
she doesn't need Sabine to become a Jedi.
She's talking
more about the technical terminology
that the Jedi had for different stages
of development in training
like Jedi Padawan, Jedi Knight,
Jedi master.
she just wants to train Sabine
to deepen her connection to the force.
And she can call herself whatever
she wants to call herself
when Harry calls in and says that
she can't give them any aid right now,
they're on their own.
That's just temporary.
But it's also because Hera is still bound
by military law,
because she's still a regular member
of the military.
She's a general.
they'll probably be some moment later on
where hair will find some way to lend them
some aid and then they'll actually learn
about Thrawn coming back for real.
It'll become a huge threat in
there'll be much easier
for her to get official resources
Then they have their big dogfight in space
with she and her team, Iraq.
It seems like the rest are being piloted
by other random mercenaries.
they all look like
they're brand new characters.
the ships that they're flying,
though, seem like prequel era designs.
And she in
Haiti is wearing a communications device
just like Enoch and Skywalker and Obi-Wan
did during Revenge of the Sith.
So these are all like super
old technology.
This fight is more about Sabine
and Ahsoka learning to work together
to operate her ship systems.
But Morgan Elspeth golden droids here,
when they start attacking also brand
new creations for the show.
The other important thing during
all these fights that they have with them
is that we finally hear Mark
the Inquisitor speak
and he has a vocoder just like Darth Vader
modulating his real voice.
But it does sound a little bit like saying
we're and he was in the credits
again under additional voices
really hoping.
Ahsoka bus his mask off during episode
four when they have a rematch
and we find out who he really is.
But the voice did definitely sound male.
there was the cool moment of Ahsoka
getting in the space.
I think it's the first time
we've seen Ahsoka wear an actual spacesuit,
taking one of the ships down
the old fashioned way outside the other
interesting thing here too is that it
doesn't sound like the dark jinn.
I really get along with Morgan Elsbeth,
even though Morgan Elspeth is ones
that paying them all this money
like she's not sounded
like she was making fun of her
for not killing us.
So going to be like,
Oh, I'll take care of it now.
that's usually the way it is amongst
evil team ups is usually
they're all not best friends,
like they're just together
because they're either being paid
well or because they want some gold,
some great power.
the other thing going on here, too,
is that you notice that Sabine is a much,
much better pilot than she is
Jedi Padawan at this point.
But remember, she has all these
mandalorian taught skills
so she would be a good pilot.
Then they fly
past a giant pod of pergolas.
You can see them briefly during episode
two in the atmosphere.
Like Baylan Skoll looks up,
you can kind of make out the shape of one
in the clouds a little bit,
That's what I was talking about earlier
in the video when I said that this planet
is kind of like the way station,
like the last gas station for the pergolas
to juice up before their long trip
to the other galaxy through hyperspace
intergalactic refueling station
that's on their path
to the other galaxy,
which they also reference
to when Hu Yang figures out
what's really going on
they get super
jazzed up at the sight of the purrgils
because they're connected to Ezra Bridgers
disappearance.
The last time they saw
them was at the battle at all
when Ezra called them to help him out
and take the Seventh Fleet,
Thorne's fleet to the other galaxy.
So he thinks it's
just another confirmation
that they're on the right path
to find them again,
this next part
was actually pretty cool, too.
Dave Filoni introducing a bunch of really,
really old school, old Republic era lore
who Yang starts talking about the truth
of what was really going on
with the giant hyperspace
ring, the pergola, their hyperspace
route to the other galaxy,
intergalactic hyperspace routes.
They said that there were records
in the Jedi Temple about intergalactic
hyperspace planes that used to follow
the per goals migration path,
but they're like ancient records
that had been lost in present day.
this goes back to what
Morgan Elspeth was talking about
when she was explaining the waypoint here
to Badlands.
Skull was built by this ancient culture
from a distant galaxy.
But they're dead in present day.
that ancient race was probably
the infinite record of empire.
They probably just found a way
to chart this path through galaxies.
Intergalactic hyperspace lines,
because hyperspace did exist back then.
The idea
is that most of the modern cultures
that you see in the Star Wars universe now
didn't really map the rest of the galaxy
until much, much later though.
But hyperspace drives themselves
did exist per their explanation
what probably wound up happening though
is that pre old republic era like before
25,000 years ago you have the full
the infinite record of empire
when they fell their technology
all their information was lost
some of it was found by people like
the knight sisters like they had the map
but the actual temples
and the waypoints were built
by the infinite record of empire.
that's why the ancient Jedi Order,
like early Old Republic
era, had records about it,
but they didn't know a whole lot about it.
much closer to present day,
Those real world facts
that Morgan Ellsworth was talking about,
like, Oh, this is a real thing
had passed to myth and legend.
And we're talked about as children stories
in the Jedi Temple,
even though the records actually
had information about this.
end, even though I didn't mention it
earlier, part of the idea, too, is
I think that the purge goals
actually come from that other galaxy,
like the Space Wells home galaxy.
Is this other parity, a galaxy.
Then we have Baylan Skoll
sending the dark Jedi
out to kill the tokens
they've been waiting at the array to fight
a soldier once
he eventually probably defeats Marrok.
They also added a credit for Marrok
in the end credits.
But it's Paul Darnell.
He's a stunt actor that's just doing
the physical performance.
Like all the fighting scenes,
like all that kind of stuff.
they do the same thing on The Mandalorian
where Pedro Pascal just as the voice,
but they have a stunt actor in the armor
or a couple of different
some actors that perform
in The Mandalorian role.
I think they're doing the same thing
with Morocco.
So fingers crossed that when a soldier
defeats him, breaks his mask
and we see the face underneath and it's
who's actually playing the character.
let me know in the comments, though,
do you agree that his modulated voice
sounds like it could be Sam Witwer
His voice just processed a whole bunch
to sound kind of like Darth Vader,
James Earl Jones type of voice
next week, though,
we have a Ahsoka versus Marrok rematch,
then Ahsoka versus Balan's skull
in a whole bunch of Anakin Skywalker
references because of his history
with Anakin Order 66.
it sounds like Ahsoka
is going to get a whole bunch of truth
jumped on her about what really happened
during order 66 and his relationship with
and again, Skywalker Sabine versus
Shin Hati rematch and more details
about what they're doing with Thrawn Ezra
during the next few episodes.
If you spotted any other Easter
eggs or references
during the episode though,
just write them below in the comments.
my Episode 4 trailer video
we'll post tomorrow in my full episode
4 video we'll post next week.
After they release it, click here
for that episode 4 video.
I think the link as soon as I posted
and click here
for all my other Ahsoka episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!